yeah thank you so welcome back to those
watching online
um so the final piece of our agenda
today is
Corporate Services we
were going to be having a bit of a chat
about climate change and principles but
what we've decided to do is we'll just
set that aside for another Workshop when
we've got a fuller Council
representation so
um corporate services so that's Patricia
and Joe welcome
hopefully my click is going to work is
it easier we just say no now no
right
so just give me your lunch we love you
as long as you don't want any more money
[Music]
the first piece of that conversation
with more than more than the second to
be frank
you've lived 10 years without it why do
you need me more
yeah
so the corporate services activity is
really everything else that Council does
that you haven't seen an activity plan
for already
so I would often be called the back
office sort of functions so we've split
it out and to the functions that are
taken so this is the people aspect
whether that be
um it includes the well-being and their
change
um culture through our customer services
and our strategic comms
Finance
um
which is we've got a financial services
team and procurement team as well uh
information and Technology
um that's their management of
information and our Information Services
and then we've got risk and Improvement
so risk teams continuous Improvement and
quality team
and health and safety so really it's
covering
and it covers a real range of activities
but it supports and enables the delivery
of those really core Council functions
making sure we can support the teams
putting water through the pipes
collecting the water making the roads
safe
so that's more an enabling and
supporting
function and then you've got the other
aspects there like we collect the racks
we set the rats we also make sure
everyone gets paid whether they're A
supplier or a staff member so there is a
it's a real range we have created a
separate activity
um
within General services so and many
other councils they don't have this as a
separate activity it's sort of all
washed out into the other main ones
we've gotten that so you can see the
transparency about how much it takes to
run the operation
so from a strategic priorities and
Community needs the most relevant ones
there is
meeting the changing needs of a
population
and making sure we deliver our services
in a way that meets those changing needs
and supporting and enabling that
um
within here you've got we've supported
the center city renewal we're enabling
and supporting a whole heap of other
things as well
but the key issues for the activity
sit in the digital transformation space
we need to transform our business to
meet both
the business needs as well as the
community expectations that they expect
us to be able to do things digitally
that we can't at the moment and the
really good example of this was the
expectation the community had that they
should have been able to receive their
rates and voices by email
we have now been able to do that but our
technology did not allow us to do that
within it we had to go and find a
another technology that would talk to it
to be able to do that
but and this is probably Joe's favorite
um thing we need service Simplicity
agility and reliability both internally
and externally
that means the customer able to deal
with this how they choose in the most
convenient way
so just on those strategic priorities
does It capture
um
you know some of that discussion we had
prior to lunch around
[Music]
was it social political pieces you know
sort of that
secular nature of our society how that's
evolving
that's probably not as relevant for this
activity as probably it is for the
Democratic process
I'm working
but it does cover off things like the
call center
um the emails coming through to us so
how information comes to us as Council
yeah and a lot of those areas are
covered in those as well yes
um regarding invoicing whether it be in
a letter or or digital
um where are we set for
taking on the task of invoicing for the
new entity three Waters
because I believe we are the invoicing
agent when the changeover happens and we
is that something that we need to think
about or yeah it is something that we
are thinking about it will be a
challenge that's why we've always said
we didn't want to do it no and and who's
it I just wondering about the expense of
the challenges the expense would be at
the I guess it's our own expense either
way whether the entity pays or
better doesn't work out as well we work
on commission I would be hoping we would
work on commission and that's what
happens in many other councils around
the country who have rates collection
yeah
um Regional councils where it's done
yeah in Scotland even though and they've
done a complete full transition now with
their this is where all the three Waters
started
um and the council invoicing was a
permanent thing
in Scotland the The Entity who ran the
water never did any invoicing full stop
so that's something to think about that
you could keep on we have we have
already got that on the radar yeah Mike
Wood and CE level was there some sort of
discussion around how that is evolving
or is it just the invoicing piece
um through software from a invoicing
perspective we've been very
um I think Direct in relation to our
position of that and that we wanted to
be separate um quite separate in
relation to the invoicing component
it's it's mixed but I think there is a
unified view that we we do want that
separated later down the track
um and there's quite an acknowledgment
there will be a transition period we
just wanted to make it very clear that
we want that transition to very period
to be as short as possible because we
don't want the confusion between What's
um the increase in cost
um being imposed and and through the
entity as opposed to uh you know the
rates increase that they might
experience from a council yeah okay
thank you so we have just to reinforce
that um I guess most of the voices I
hear uh want us to differentiate away
from the collection of rates for three
Waters on two levels
um the government is saying clearly for
the next
um they say the short to medium term
whatever that means that we will
continue to collect the water rates or
the three water rates the downside of it
is that most councils actually don't
want that to be included in the overall
rate tape first and then separate it out
they want it separated out before it's
sent out so you're basically getting two
rate bills so that then the question is
is why is my water rates gone from 800
to 1200 overnight then you can say well
you need to talk to the entity about
that you don't need to be talking to
your local Council yeah that's right so
I'm not sure there's an answer to that
yet wish there was but don't have that
yeah there's a few issues okay
so but it is a problem yeah 100
okay so from a current budget the
operational expenditure is
um sitting around the 14 million dollars
um predominantly that is in people but a
lot of it is in services so that's
taking us currently 102 FTA to operate
these at these support activities
that's a it's a it's a significant chunk
of council across this all
um from a capital expenditure is
um that includes a lot of that that is
predominantly in our I.T space
so your laptops iPads networks and the
like
um
the relation to maintaining our levels
of service
um the biggest push in this is about
getting council's digital resources up
to speed
um
there's a lot as we all know there's a
large technology curve
um our systems are well behind that
curve
and we need to start moving back up the
curve to be much toward not at the coal
face just behind it
um so there is a lot of activity
um in there and that's probably the
biggest request that will come through
in the budget bids that you'll see later
that is
the cost of getting to that
um that point we need to be making in
making information and data easy to
access and to use
both to enable externals external people
to access their data and use it but also
the internal Council services
so that they can get the data that they
need easily and can use it I mean and
interpret it
um
and even to maintain their current
levels of service resourcing as a real
challenge
it's getting the right people at the
right level
within their budget parameters into
invercargill especially within our
information technology Information
Services and even Finance Fields getting
those right skills is a challenge
and we need and probably the biggest
challenge to the activities continuing
to ensure that the rest of the internal
Council business and staff are supported
and their obligations that we have met
opportunities for cost savings
um no direct opportunities have been
identified however we're continuing to
look for improvements in both their
processes and our systems that will
result in efficiency gains gains in
decision making and improved capacity
um and should support better value and
purchase deals so
while we won't see significant cost
savings within this activity we should
be able to
constrained costs rather than um
look for big savings
now on the options for Council to
consider
but most significant to be Advanced is
the implementation of an of every RP
technology solution so council's already
decided that it wants to go down an Erp
technology and we've selected that
and bring in most of their operational
systems and data onto a single platform
the cost to do that implementation
um is currently still being worked with
that's the current estimate but it could
be a little bit more this is to actually
get it up and running
licensing is one factor implementing the
system getting a data working is
probably the biggest part and changing
our systems internally to allow that
um so that's where we sit there the
other aspect is in relation to the
corporate Fleet so their Fleet sits with
the exception of the parks Fleet sits
within this activity
so that's um the vehicles that you see
signed written with the invercargill
city council we've got a strategy
present to move the corporate Fleet as
it goes through renewal to hybrids where
hybrids are available
um
at the moment we haven't moved to going
to more electric we do have some
electric within the fleet because of the
restrictions on charging capacity
um in the area
but it's whether we get the direction
from Council through versus to move to
go to Electric from the hybrid and we
would just do that within their existing
renewal budget but at the moment we've
just stayed in that
one foot on either side of the fence and
stayed with hybrids before moving to go
to that electric option
um just with the contemplation of
electric does council do an exercise to
be fully aware of the end of life of an
electric vehicle and what where it goes
I mean you just don't want to go I don't
I don't care but obviously are we
worried about end-of-life electric
vehicle and what it
where does it go
um
we haven't as yet but our one vehicle is
getting towards because getting closer
to its end of life and we are thinking
about whether that is the best way and
that's part of the cons reasons why we
haven't jumped into electric already was
the charging and the whole of Life yeah
okay so I I mean it'd be a tough one to
do I mean how are you going to find out
no one's going to give you a straight
answer no and because we tend to not
hold them till the end of end of life ah
so there's one more user or several or
several so we do deal with it
appreciation we're making someone else's
problem oh yeah never we should still be
thinking about it you're looking for a
car I agree
give me the golf cart Berry yeah we're
looking at bus fleet as well for this so
within this activity the bus fleet
doesn't sit within this that sits within
the public transport activity
and I know they are thinking it then
so a couple of questions on their
um technology piece
um
contract
a partner that we're working with to
deliver that program because we have got
a partner that's delivering that for us
we are still in the early procurement of
a full partner for the full
yeah I like it so will that
contract include
um
you know some well they just deliver it
and then leave or will they stay on to
make sure we read the efficiencies and
benefits of the
technology platform for that sort of
been negotiated through but we have as
an outcome we would be looking to make
sure that we have
reaped all the benefits that we were
looking for so so will the the contract
you'll have warranties in it around
there
proof of use and all those sorts of
goods there there should be some of
those we are not even at Contract stage
yet no no there will be some of those
yeah
yeah okay and then the vehicle Fleet
have we thought about what thinking
about that asset is in a different
way around
it's an asset
well it's it's Capital we have but as is
this could we release
some of the service capability of that
asset to make it available to the
community for them to use at some time
that is an option we could consider
because I think some other councils do
that don't they yeah there is some
councils using um shared Flight Services
and more Metro areas yeah because
there's a lot of cars sitting on that
car back on the weekend isn't it
that we could use to service some so you
know Community need
that wouldn't probably fully recover
costs but it meets a social or some
other needle
just thinking about it could be a raft
of insurance issues yeah there is there
is a raft of risk issues associated with
that yeah
we've got an Uber Fleet out there yeah
we don't have a rid of a cargo okay we
might it could be an ICC Uber
why not we bought a lotto shop anyway
it's challenging the thinking
okay
um unlike all the other activities just
seen this activity currently has no Audi
of service
however we want to introduce them
um we want to introduce some measures
that reflect the enabling and supporting
role of the activity we are at the
moment proposing three key ones um being
the percentage of requests for service
under investigation and close within
five working days of being raised
um we have set that we have set that
level low and aspirationally towards 95
onwards towards 95 percent
um recognizing that that would be a
significant change in process
and the recording of that will have its
challenges but we've got plenty of time
the next one was the customer as a
provider with a 24 hour seven day a week
call center 99 of the time at one
percent is to allow for disruptions such
as if we lose the internet
um
and face-to-face customer services in
invercargill with some minimum hours and
Bluff with the minimum as
and if anybody's wondering why Bluff has
more hours than them for cargo it's
because of Sid Lotto shop
and we've put another one in there the
percentage of suppliers who are paid on
time
that is where it's a forward-looking one
because I suspect looking at our cousins
across the ditch the New Zealand
government will start requiring us to
report that the Australian government
already requires its local government
and state government and government
entities to report that
what's the impasse to not paying on time
is it technology
um could be technology and voice gets
lost
argument
would be excluding dispute of invoice so
this was assuming that everything's okay
with invoice it's just not paid on time
or is this including a speedometer but
this would be Cloud disputed advice as
well it's a wee bit different so it's a
little bit different um if you were
trying to cut the disputes out it would
be too difficult to measure
um so that's why we've allowed um often
we have a number of suppliers that still
don't provide different voices to the
centralized
um email address so therefore if we
don't know about it we can't chase it
for them right
and here we don't record how many
invoices are in dispute or we couldn't
um we can now but it's just trying to
get those reports we'll get those
reports pulled together I'm getting much
closer to getting a feel yeah that we
are it might be once we start putting
this together we might adjust these
numbers these percentages
um before we put the ltp out
just comment that it's uh good that the
council has actually fall into
a very high percentage of being paid on
time so that's good
and the other thing is the uh just want
to talk about the after hour call center
I I
believe it's the Water Tower or
something is it it's an extremely good
service uh it's probably not designed to
be like that but on but fortunately the
people who do Man it are very responsive
genuinely caring and and interested in
any call that comes in it's a amazing
service
um and hope that doesn't change
surely we must be able to have that
percentage of pliers supplies higher
than 85 percent if if we excluded the
ones that weren't in dispute we should
be able to separate that data out
because 15 of your supplies given that
some of these are very reliant on
getting an on-time payment
um but like my view a lot of the
government departments would not accept
that well it's just about being a good
corporate citizen isn't it yeah yeah it
is yeah yeah it's not a bad percentage
normal trading business point of view
it's quite high percentage
yours should always look at what you're
paying
and that's where your disputes arrive
and and this is also in recognition that
some suppliers insist on seven day terms
yeah and a large organization
we're 20 standard terms of the 20th of
the month of the following invoice
so that would flag up on this report
then Rock
um we're just
this is we're still working through how
the report exactly would work yeah so
This Is Us coming up with performance
measures they might have to type their
tweaked as we work out how to
operationalize them yeah
this one question under being paid on
time now where they're all organized
organization like us you the contractor
gets uh or number
and that's related to a quote that he
submitted and he gets to go ahead he
finds the ordinary he finds invoice in
whichever has that reference number does
it then have to go to the appropriate
Department to be signed off yes like one
two three four or whatever floor okay
and is there uh does each floor have its
own sort of accounting person or does it
have to go to the individual sort of
who've contracted the work so it but
this is getting quite operational in our
counselor but although they have to to
understand this so this is where you
would go um come in it would be sent to
the person who raised that they should
have Goods receipted or service
receipted that purchase order that
they've received it because the finance
team can't pay the invoice until they
know that the services if that person's
away
you know just don't like the other they
have you know annual leave and
everything does that trip the system up
um they should have put a delegation in
for someone else right to do that I mean
I've struck this personally with
organizations myself in a previous life
so the questions actually help
autonomous is the system yeah
and I think that's part of the IIT
investment that is part of the
investment it is relative it's it is
much better than it was yes yeah but it
still has flaws because people can still
ignore the system yeah yeah
it still requires someone to say yes I
have received that okay
still don't understand I guess from an
accounting perspective why we don't have
figures very close to 100 right along
that line
um you know if we had if we had a kpi
that said
putting aside the non-disputed ones for
non-disputed ones that they should be
100 given that's 20 the following month
we've got at least
20 calendar days to achieve that to go
beyond that
potentially 15 to go beyond that I just
I don't get that yeah well I think
that's where that that I I sense you're
probably you've got a bit of a gap in
your numbers you're trying to measure
because you you've got a few vagaries
you've got to try on and it's also
because we're not measuring I could have
the the often when you put up new
measures you'll see staff members that
will put them up and go Baseline to be
provided which I could have said let's
do it in the first year to determine the
Baseline I decided that that wasn't
that wasn't good for so I've come up
with a number that should be achievable
um and jump them up it may be that we
can come to the next ltp and we'll jump
them up if I managed to get this
reporting in place beforehand we may be
able to change it before the ltp goes in
and it may start at 19 or 95.
come on about you again
I I still don't understand why we're
talking about 85.95 reckon I mean why
wouldn't we have a benchmark that
basically says
um unless it's in dispute which can be
at either end yeah
um it should be paid on time so that's a
hundred percent as a Target figure and
if you don't achieve it then you'll
report on why you haven't achieved it
yeah if you sent the Mitch Mark too low
potentially we could sit there and Pat
ourselves on the back and say oh look
we've done well we've got 86 well that's
15 of our clients that we're Contracting
work to that haven't been paid on time
given it's not it's not a five-day
payment it's it you know it could be
that you put an invoice in on the first
week of the month and you don't get paid
to the following 20th so six weeks later
at the shortest it's least nearly three
weeks later into the month to the 20th
of the following month yeah just don't
get there there's no alternative trade
obviously normal terms of trade yeah I
know it is but what I'm saying is if you
get paid by the 20th of the following
month that's great I don't have any
problems with that whether it's six
weeks or three weeks makes no difference
to me a lot of the invoices in seven
days seven day payments so they
immediately go into dispute but it's not
really dispute they're not going to get
paid all through the department because
you can't sit down and do invoicing
until such time as we've made some
significant changes in our um
Contracting process to ensure that our
contract terms and conditions are
aligned uh with our payment terms uh
were their suppliers which there are a
number of areas where we're operating on
a good faith with our suppliers
that and that won't come through in
those stats the stats will be based on
what's in the contract
um we wouldn't be able to do that in the
first year because some of those terms
will say the seven day terms but the
contract is quite happy to accept the
fact that we would be 20 days but we'd
need to get the contracts amended that's
a legacy issue that we're working
through
um
that'll take quite a bit to work through
there's quite a number of contracts in
there
but if if it was to have something
around the dispute side of it then you
could fairly quickly work that through
but uh you'll never get I would say
you'd never get to 100 from that
perspective there's always those loads
instances that have been talked about
where somebody is away and those
delegations you do need to allow that
five percent slippage where that could
occur and it it it's not not something
that you can necessarily manage because
it could be um actor guards and those
sort of things that come in that
situation yes just a final thing so you
know when you've got a subjected tiger
that says paid on time I mean that that
should probably say paid by the 20th of
the appointment
so if you say that then the challenges
then to get your contracts with these
suppliers in place so it's not five days
or seven days or whatever yeah because
on time it's very subjective
um yeah yeah you're right so yeah paid
in the 20th month yep
and then the challenge for the staff in
the first 12 months is to make sure that
all the subsequent contracts I have say
that 20th of a month or make
arrangements for a shorter time but
that's the the furthest it goes because
you don't want a situation where
potentially
um Patricia could have somebody
Downstream from her in this in the
authorization away on leave and nobody
else is authorizing the payments and so
it's the 20th of the following month
um and then you got the scrantable
customers saying hey this is not good
enough we've got cash flow issues yeah
yeah that would never happen logic all
right um last one that yeah just look
this 20th month is I mean my last a few
years of training was my previous
business
20th month was Draconian I mean we would
see from from very good you know
um people we work with the bill would
come in 23rd paid on the but was always
paid before the 30th and and I think
that's a more acceptable
sort of thing now
um I I thought I certainly got used to
it
um running the business and this 20th of
the month I think is I don't know I mean
it's a it's pretty standard but it's
pretty old as well I I think the
flexibility I don't know very in your
business well you've got it mine's
usually
paid 40 inch like 14 days well yeah I
know but your business is quite a bit
smaller than accountability yeah you
know but the the 20th is is I don't know
it's pretty standard in in large scale
anyway is that all your invoices so you
get the whole month together and you sit
down yeah that's right they don't always
come in for the proof no that's right
after the end of the month yeah no no
it's just the technicality yeah so
you've heard the messaging and yeah we
want the highest possible standard
around it and we want to be a really
good corporate citizen I think is the
overall summary of the discussion
okay
so in relation to asset plans the Corp
s the corpus's activities supported by
both the property asset plan
but also Information Services have
prepared an asset plan as well
um and that is in relation to our plans
in relation to our technology
and their technology Networks
um and there is some significant
investment being identified with in
there on the um
within the um on the renewal of the
technology Networks
um in relation to the corporate Fleet
um we have optimized that flat
significantly in the last two years so
we are we have um running at a
quite High utilization of the fleet
um and unless indicated elsewhere we'll
continue with that Fleet renewal to with
hybrids were available
and noting that the safety rating of the
fleet continues to be monitored and
maximized so we make sure that the
vehicles that we do have in the later
sitting at that higher end of the safety
rating and that dictates what we
purchase as well
and you'll notice that the flat wall can
as it's replaced is coming in and white
vehicles
um this might be a bit picky but with
the choice of a vehicle and
standardization obviously if you went
and I don't know where our European
wants the change between a a Japanese or
a car and a European one decided the
indicator so we do we have any because
you know people jump into cars it's not
their own yeah do we I mean as far as
safety goes you would hope for a
standardization
we're trying to find standardization
um though there is a checklist given to
staff when they do jump in to a vehicle
to that they should do before they set
off to check which side the indicators
do operate on that vehicle versus some
of the other ones yeah look it's just
one of those things that
just like picking up a rental car you
check which side the indicators are
working off and that when you're
traveling yourselves
are we two things I guess um one is a
replacement of technology so I guess on
an ongoing basis we have a need to
dispose of computer wear and upgrade do
we have any ability to move that on to
other parties or do we just throw it
away
um where possible we do try and move it
on
um I am not 100 sure
um if we're actually doing that often
some of our stuff is towards the end of
its useful life
uh why I ask because
we've been trying to help
um James Ward who you'll know as uh
around his Esports and one of the things
that he needs is he needs computer
screens and and some some other
companies H J's and others have been
providing him with that what they call
end of life but it's not really the end
of life
um it's not the hardware he's looking
for he's just looking for the terminal
so just so that might be an option for
us to to help him out the other issue
was the issue I think early on which I
missed that you said is no opportunities
for savings so I guess and Joe won't
like this but I mean maybe a challenge
for her could be to develop a paper
someone online that says well while we
don't have any opportunity for savings
within our current organization what
happens if we combine with the
environment Southland or alternatively
if we get an
um
a push for amalgamation of council given
that a lot of services you get up on the
screen there are actually things that
are common to all councils could we get
some economy of scale on there and what
would that actually look like
now I know that's that's not an easy
report to write and it might take some
time but I think as we go forward that
would be quite helpful to have as part
of our discussion yeah is that something
the regional Merrell Forum could sponsor
well uh I mean Michael's already flagged
with us that
um there may be some potential in the
future for an invercargill and
environment itself than to come by yeah
um which is probably not where I'd like
us to go I think it's better to combine
the three councils if we go down that
track and leaving Warren and Southland
as a Regional Council sitting to the
side with the environmental stuff
they've currently got and add to it
climate change so that we're not all
shoveling around about what sort of
vehicles we should have it should be
standard across them yeah um but if we
do for accommodation these get into bed
with them I think would be helpful for
us to scope you know uh what would the
bin for be to our organization could we
share costs on quite a few of the fronts
that were up there before yeah
the best use of resource there that the
Chiefs agree that hey this is something
they want to explore in their own
organizations so almost you've got to
mandate you could go and explore that
and then you don't have a mandates or
just waste the diamond effort would be
my thinking
sure so I think it needs to come back to
us in the mail for them
the regional one
Michael's not being excited by that
thought if you read the body language
I'm trying to protect you
um throw yourself chair a little happy
to take it on board but
um we'd be more having discussions at
the moment where it's
um prudent to from a location point of
view and also we actively have
discussions around shared service um
components
they happen reasonably regularly we
haven't discussed at this point with any
amalgamation from those sort of point of
views
um just being very clear but we have we
have obviously discussed where we can
share resources across and we've got
examples of that already going on around
GIS Etc
or good comments to consider thank you
the as people are starting to move more
onto digital networks there are often
less people coming through the front
door so there are lots of other duties
that front of house has taken on you
know they do lots of the balancing of
the accounts and the mail room
Etc so we do look to increase things
they're doing outside of just customers
walking through the door as well
particularly for that front of house
space and the numbers have been reduced
so roles Scopes changing exactly yeah
and they are multi-functional really
across customer service now to enable
them to sort of jump in and do other
things yeah yeah it's good
that's
that was the last slide so anything else
in relation to this activity that you
want put into the activity plan
oh just probably the one thing is we've
always seemed to struggled that's
probably something for Michael to talk
about around getting
um
the right sort of Finance people
sometimes and I guess we're now
targeting it as well and that
um it's always there are scarce resource
both finance and audit type finance
and we're pushing towards it
Specialists as well is that going to be
a sort of
an area we're going to struggle with we
have to compete
is the it specific to us like to local
bodies or could we take an I.T person
who might be sitting in a
somewhere else or
through self-chair it's an interesting
one it is is at times pretty unique in
relation to the different
um software you were using
having said that we're trying to push
with this one Council to go on to a more
industry sort of platform
that will have longer term benefits for
the industry
um from that perspective and there is a
few across the country that are trained
in that so it's probably uh
a better skill set across the local
government sector but it has a
significant issue in relation to the
support model across
um across New Zealand from that
perspective so we are looking at how we
can complement that from overseas as
well to go through the project we will
have resourcing challenges in both areas
ongoing without doubt they are areas
longer term that we would need to
consider as councils how we
resources and support those I actually
think it's a piece that local government
New Zealand need to pick up because this
is something that every Council does
this these functions right they're
vagaristic but fundamentally they all
have I T Systems they all have Finance
systems and you know I know Michael and
I have had the discussion if we go into
or negotiate with an sap or someone
we've got little clout but if local
government New Zealand went on the
collective with all the councils the
negotiated package for all councils we
would get significant different service
level provision
in follow-up on all those good stuff so
I think it's a real area that local
government New Zealand can actually lean
into and add value back to us as
individual councils why the
collectiveness of the service and the
asset that we're trying to purchase I
guess the downside of that is if we get
in collectively and the government's
experiences then when you have I don't
know 50 something councils all wanting
same protect more I.T people because
we're all on the same platform
um nobody wants to live on the west
coast south island nobody wants to come
to invercargill nobody wants to go to
kaitaia or wherever
um and so you while you while you might
be not competing International you're
competing with your other Bigger
Brothers elsewhere no I was making more
the purchase of the actual systems yeah
there's still a staff thing and but
that's a challenge we have across here
in it isn't it we heard it this morning
with the water management people I mean
you know heaps of energy but closer to
the you know our renewable asset well I
guess what I was getting at with my
question was once we have the technology
in place that we want to do all the
things that we want to do
we then need to have some bums on seats
and invercargill to manage that or is
that can that be done from a distance
and so if we're looking for extra it are
we looking for people not necessarily to
manage that platform but to have the
sort of skill set that we've got
upstairs or any of the people that can
turn the hand to a lot of different
things
yeah
through yourself to your just to
highlight the technology challenges that
our sector has there's currently 78
different ways of doing technology
within councils it is possible to have
one system I think Australia has a
slightly better model in place but they
still probably
have a dozen or so different types of
ways of doing things until we do have an
industry push in relation to one one way
of doing it then we will
um forever be having to have localized
resource to support the different
Technologies
um
that will will have um the potential to
be able to centralize some of those
resources should you you know should we
get that push as an industry
thank you thank you yeah that's it
that's it
we're well ahead of time
but I think you okay well we're pretty
much finished now aren't we so process
from here just to reiterate where we get
to
certain activity managers will take your
feedback so the more feedback you can
give on those sheets as well as what
you've given verbally is really helpful
um they will finalize the draft text of
the asset and activity management plans
and budget workshops will be the next
step in terms of the dollars
um draft activity and asset plans will
be with you either in November or
December to be formally received and
that's ahead of everything being adopted
prior to consultation in February
and thank you to those that joined us on
the live stream